foreign
[Music]
Maniacs religious zealots conspiracy
theorists and other decent good
Americans and worldwide citizens I'm
Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
direct message it is Monday January 24th
in the year
2022 and we are live streaming of course
on rumble.com on YouTube and on blazetv
please do me a favor make sure that
you're subscribed wherever you watch and
you can share you can tap notification
bells and the rest of it uh we once
again are in our temporary Studio here
which we're making some adjustments on
things are coming together I know there
were some audio issues last week I think
everything's going to start shaking out
this week uh and most importantly all of
my stuff from Los Angeles I am being
told is on a truck right now and it's
getting here so I won't have to sit on
an Ikea chair which is what I did all
weekend I just sat on one IKEA chair and
I ate from one Ikea plate and I drank
from one Ikea glass so I'm very excited
we got a great show for you today
especially this first segment where I
really want to do a deep dive on
something that's been driving me crazy
we're going to be covering a bit of what
happened on Real Time with Bill Maher on
Friday night you guys know my feelings
about Bill Maher I think he's one of the
last good decent liberals but he seems
to be unable to get to the conclusion
which is that you cannot be a Democrat I
always say you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a Democrat
he had Barry Weiss on Barry Weiss is
sort of in that half liberal kind of
thing and basically she just said a
bunch of stuff related to covid that all
of us have been saying for about two
years pretty much every conservative
insane person has been saying for two
years but then when she said it oh
lockdowns aren't good we're causing kids
to have depression Etc the the internet
over the weekend went bananas and it was
like oh a liberal finally said something
saying and this leads me to my my
struggle with this issue and I'm sort of
friendly with Barry so it's it makes it
doubly compounding so I want to dive
into a whole bunch of things we've got a
whole bunch of video clips for you on
that then our our immigration secretary
is basically saying hey we're not going
to arrest you if you're here illegally
that's a problem uh finally oh no then
two more uh CNN have you heard of this
network really terrible place a bunch of
crazy people on there just lies more
more lies we'll get to that and then the
Joe Biden guy that uh you know they put
out out there every now and again to say
a bunch of stuff and read poorly off the
teleprompter and the rest of it uh his
approval is plummeting and he's got a
whole bunch of other problems before I
get to any of that I just thought I
would tell you one quick story in 30
seconds which is I had some friends in
town uh last night friends from Los
Angeles who are considering moving here
like everybody else and we're sitting
there
add a little tequila we're chatting
about life and it's like they're here in
Florida they've been here for a couple
days like they're smiling they're happy
got a little Sun like feeling good about
everything realized just about the
energy here and the business and the
opportunity all of that stuff uh and my
friend she's going on and on about how
horrible it is there and the crime in
Los Angeles and they're hearing gunshots
for the first time she shows me a
picture of literally of a needle sitting
right side or outside of her office her
office which is on a pretty decent
Street and they're going on and on about
the problems there and I'm looking at my
two friends it's a married couple I'm
looking at two of them I'm like
all right are you guys crazy like just
get going just get going and that is my
message to all of you that are in these
crazy places get going we want you here
in the good places to help us build and
help us fight so otherwise it's just
like you're crazy people you're crazy
people who live around crazy people and
that until you leave the craziness the
craziness is part of your life but it
ain't part of my life because I live
here in Florida all right let's talk
about convention Estates and then get to
all the stories guys uh President Joe
Biden is ruining our country
true there's really no other way to say
it he's destroyed the economy he's
embarrassed us on the world stage he's
failed to promise to his he's failed in
his promise to end covid and now he's
working to federalize all elections the
question for us is what are we going to
do about it you know that I don't like
empty talk I don't like political games
I like real solutions I like people who
do things and that's exactly what I
found in the convention of States
project led by my friend Mark meckler a
great guy the convention of States
project is seeking to call an article 5
Convention of States at this convention
the states gather to propose
Constitutional Amendments that limit
Federal power and yes that includes the
power of our wonderful President Joe
Biden I'm not alone in supporting the
call for this convention Glenn Beck
Governor Ron DeSantis and Mark Levin
have all voiced their support for this
initiative and you can too go to
conventionofstates.com today and sign
the petition to demand that your state
legislators vote Yes to Convention of
States convention Estates legislation is
pending across the country stop
complaining and do something visit
convention estates.com and sign the
petition today again that's
conventionofstates.com Dave and now back
to me and by the way I think in uh
October if I'm not mistaken I'll be
speaking at a Convention of state's
convention uh which will be here in
Orlando in the yes free state of Florida
okay so let's talk about uh Bill Maher
and Barry White so you all know who Bill
Maher is of course he has been the
standard bearer of liberalism of leftism
in America for probably about 30 years
right he was a big comic in the 80s then
he got the show Politically Incorrect
which was a precursor to real time you
may remember that Politically Incorrect
was actually canceled it was an early
cancel culture victim it was canceled
because right after 9 11 Bill Maher went
on television it was on ABC at the time
and he went on and basically said hey
you can say a lot of things about these
jihadists these people who flew planes
into these buildings but you can't say
that they aren't brave because look at
what they did now of course that was
misconstrued and maybe he used language
in a bit of a sloppy way and everything
else but the show in essence was
canceled a few months later so he's he's
been around the block
and you guys know Bill Maher has been
great against wokism he has been great
against identity politics he has been
great when it comes to talking about
Free Speech all of these things however
he does always call all Republicans
racist Donald Trump's a Nazi he still
loves all the big government stuff but
he's kind of getting there and I
basically like the guy and I want him to
get there I know a little something
about the adventure of a liberal
actually waking up actually being red
pilled and getting to the end of the
road right now another person you could
put in that bucket is Barry Weiss Barry
Weiss of course was a columnist at the
New York Times and she she actually
wrote the original piece about the
intellectual dark web which was about me
and Jordan Peterson and the weinsteins
and Sam Harris and everybody else that
sort of blew up the whole thing I'll get
to that more in just a second but about
two years ago Barry Weiss left the New
York Times because she could not deal
with the wokeness the identity politics
stuff she felt it was it was in
intolerable place to work so I hold her
in high regard in that sense now she was
on real time this past Friday talking
about covid and I think what you're
going to see is she's going to make a
whole hell of a lot of sense
well you decide no I'm done with coven
oh I'm done it's like I I went so hard
on kovid I yeah I remember read the
Pringles cans that I bought at the
grocery store strip my clothes off
because I thought kovid would be on my
clothes like I did it all I watched
Tiger King I got to the end of Spotify
like we all did it right
a lot of us did do it and then we were
told you get the vaccine you get the
vaccine and you get back to normal and
we haven't gotten back to normal and
it's ridiculous at this point
I know that so many of my liberal and
Progressive friends are with me on this
and they do not want to say it out loud
because they are scared to be called
anti-vaxx or to be called science denial
or to be you know smeared as a Trumper
I'm sorry if you believe the science you
will look at the data that we did not
have two years ago and you will find out
that cloth masks do not do anything you
will realize that you can show your
vaccine passport at a restaurant and
still be asymptomatic in carrying
Omicron and you will realize most
importantly that this is going to be
remembered by the younger generation as
a catastrophic moral crime
the city of Flint Michigan which is 80 I
think minority students has just
announced indefinite virtual schooling
in the past two years we've seen among
young girls a 51 increase in self-harm
people are killing themselves they are
anxious they are depressed they are
lonely that is why we need to end it
more than any inconvenience that it's
been to the rest of us I think
it's a pandemic it's like at this point
it's a pandemic of bureaucracy
okay so there's a lot there so first off
I just want to say I'm sort of friendly
with Barry she has been to my house
multiple times for dinner she's been
over for parties we've gone out okay I
don't think she is a bad person and
obviously what she's saying there is
right but here's the problem
there's a whole bunch of us and I'm not
making this about me there's a gajillion
people out there that have been saying
this all along now most of those people
happen to be scary conservatives that
were anti-lockdown and
anti-mandate and all of those things and
by the way as I've said many times I
grant everyone a Long Leash in that
first month if you were spraying your
Pringle cans down and I was washing an
egg crate and all of the nonsense that
they had us do in that first month it
was just haywire and and I suppose there
were a few people who truly truly saw
what was happening right from the beat
but I'll Grant everybody a Long Leash
for that first month now everything that
Barry said there was right about all
that stuff and the depression and all of
those things with kids we talk about
this on the show all the time obviously
now the problem is at the end there well
there's several problems but at the end
there the last line she says this is a
pandemic of bureaucracy except she's for
the bureaucracy Bill Maher is for the
bureaucracy they love Democrats she's
talking about what they're doing in
Michigan to kids okay Michigan is run by
Gretchen Whitmer a Democrat she is
sitting next to actually why don't we
pull it up right now the Tweet uh the uh
Richie Torres thing so she's sitting
next to while she's talking the guy that
I think you see in the video there is a
guy by the name of Richie Torres who's a
congressman from New York who again I
think is probably a halfway decent
liberal he's not a complete nut bag but
here's his Twitter profile he's got his
gender pronouns in there so this is what
liberals do with everything it's like
you guys create all of the problems and
then for the last two years as she
pointed out oh there are these good
progressives and liberals that don't
want to be called trumpers well she and
especially Bill Maher you guys have run
around calling the rest of us racist and
backwards and religious Freaks and
zealots and all of those things so it's
like if you guys get everything wrong
for two years right or you're always
behind and then you get it roughly right
then what what is it that we do like if
you're if your conclusion is still okay
vote for Democrats if your conclusion is
okay give more tax money to the
bureaucracy that you're attacking if
you're if you see the road and you take
the road and you understand what's
happening and then there's the end of
the road and you just kind of look back
and you go well I can't get to the end
of the road because the end of the road
is yes these people gotta go and yes
maybe conservatives are conserving
something Freedom which is what Liberals
are supposed to want to conserve uh so
you can see that this is a little bit
messy here and the reason that it really
kind of got on my radar this weekend
because I've known about this I've been
frustrated about this sort of thing
obviously for quite some time but then I
saw a gazillion conservatives applauding
basically like oh my God Barry Weiss
isn't she amazing and Bill Maher in real
time it's so incredible what they're
doing because they're saying something
true because finally a liberal doesn't
seem like a complete lunatic so even
people that I totally like so clay
Travis tweeted this it was also shared
by Ted Cruz I consider both of these
guys friends I like them so this is not
attacking them in any way I'm bringing
it up to to point out the specific
specific issue here clay Travis said on
Twitter the most impressive thing about
Barry Weiss on last night's Bill Maher
is the wild Applause after she finishes
here after two years the tithes are
turning even for the left-leaning people
in this country when it comes to covet
so of course what Clay is saying and
what Ted Cruz shared of course that's
right and it's good right we want to see
these lefties move right we want to see
these people wake up and this is one of
those airlock moments you may remember a
couple months ago when Jon Stewart went
on The Colbert Show and all of us for
about a year and a half were at least
somewhat talking about the possibility
that kovid was from the Wuhan lab and
that it got leaked out right a whole
bunch of us were talking about it we
were all conspiracy theorists and I'm
sure we were somehow racist because of
that and the rest of it well then
suddenly the mainstream media felt oh
well Jon Stewart he's a good liberal and
he went on the show of a good liberal
and they talked about something so now
the mainstream media suddenly could talk
about it and it was suddenly on CNN and
Washington Post and everywhere else this
moment with Weiss and Mar is one of
those airlock moments it's like now
people are going to start talking about
it because they see the writing on the
wall right they see the polls where
Democrats are going to get absolutely
slaughtered in the midterms where three
weeks ago during Christmas when everyone
got covered vaccinated or not and it all
became obvious that it was all [ __ ]
they see the writing on the wall but
again that's good you want people to
wake up you want people to evolve been
there done that wrote a book about it I
get it that's what that's what being a
functioning human is all about like
getting new information living something
and then and then figuring out how you
want to move forward with it that's what
it's all about so you can see where the
conflict is here if at the end you're
still
for the Democrats the people that are
locking you down if at the end you still
think all the conservatives who you run
around call racist and everything else
are wrong about everything then then
what is a good liberal at this point I
get it they're better than the worksters
there's no question about it okay get it
true absolutely but at the end if your
conclusions are to vote for the very
things that you endlessly rail against
that are coming for your free speech
that are bringing in this neo-racism
that are locking you down and all of
those things just because you've spent
so much time calling the other guys
racist
then perhaps
perhaps you need a mirror maybe I'll
send them a mirror can I can I get all
right Amazon sells mirrors or somewhere
sells mirrors I think I have to go back
to Ikea later I'm going to send Barry
Weiss and Bill Maher a mirror I want to
go a little a little further on this uh
Mike uh John cardillo uh who's a great
guy who I was uh I had dinner with at
the DeSantis event I was at a couple
weeks ago he had an interesting tweet
that then was uh tweet retweeted by Mike
cernovich that I think explains a little
bit of this a little bit further so John
cardillo said this country is about to
make a hard right turn the left has no
idea what's coming then Mike cernovich
who I've had on the show a couple times
I consider a friend uh he retweeted and
he said something that I think gets to
the heart of this he says yes sir that's
why the moderate left Democrat voters
are trying to pace and Lead
conservatives by pretending they give a
[ __ ] about the lives destroyed by the
woke left they aren't needed and
conservative simping for TV man said
good has to stop so you see what he's
saying there he's basically saying so
all these people who get it wrong these
these good liberals right these good
liberals because they're not woke but
they kind of get it
and then they go on television and they
say something sane and then we all
applaud oh my God they're not all
completely bananas that it's actually a
problem because they would gladly throw
us under the bus when when the day comes
unless they're willing to make that
final that final step now the reason I
thought the cernovich tweet and I know
this maybe feels a little Insider
baseball but I'm trying to paint a case
here okay uh the reason I thought the
cernovich Tweet was interesting was
because if you remember and I'm sure
many of you do the original article
about the intellectual dark web that
Barry wrote In The New York Times that
that the wokesters tried to cancel her
for she had a line in there that if
you're an interviewer and in this case
she was talking about me and Joe Rogan
specifically she said if you talk to
people like cernovich and she actually
used his name if you talk to people like
cernovich I think she also mentioned
Alex Jones she'd said you'd have to be
cynical or stupid and she repeatedly
before the article was public public
asked me to basically say I regret doing
my interview with cernovich I've never
interviewed Alex Jones so that was the
one she was really hung up on I should
just if I would just say that I did
something wrong that that line wouldn't
be in the in the piece itself after the
piece was published he told me that the
the publisher forced or the editor
forced her to put it in but I think it's
I think you get the point here so let's
let's move uh forward a little bit to
now Bill Maher talking about Florida
because I think again you will see all
right you got the ideas right but are we
going to get to the end of the road are
we going to get to that that golden pot
at the end of that rainbow which is in
Florida take a look Florida like stayed
open I mean I I was just in Florida I've
been there a few times since this
started half of New York has moved there
the atmosphere is just different I'm not
moving to Florida I'm not promoting
Florida I'm just saying AOC just went to
Florida and had a good time without a
mask okay
I'm just saying I've been to Florida the
atmosphere was just night and day from
California which was gloomy and
everything was the The Andromeda Strain
was out there and you went to and you
went to Florida and I'm just saying yes
there are different factors and
differences but basically it's like they
stayed open and went on with life and
they didn't do a hell of a lot worse and
maybe did that you know I just realized
the way we do this show my mic is cut
obviously when we're showing you a video
clip right there and basically I'm just
screaming and cursing at Connor and
Michael about what we're watching and
then we come back to me and then I
somewhat cool off but do you see what
the problem is do you get it people Bill
Maher I'm not moving to Florida I'm not
he has to preface it by saying somehow
Florida is bad I have been in Florida
for one month Florida is [ __ ]
spectacular that's sorry about the I had
to do it it is spectacular I went to
Whole Foods yesterday I was mobbed by
people every single person welcome to
Florida we're so happy you're here big
smiles on their face people wanted to
buy me things at Whole Foods you don't
have to buy me food
but so he has to preface it by saying
I'm not moving there because the
implication is Florida's red and this
Ron DeSantis guy is a bad dude he's a
mean man but then he also acknowledges
AOC vacations here swallow vacations
here that [ __ ] gretton wittmer
I also had a lot of coffee this morning
she also vacations here they all get it
but they won't get to there so what what
do you mean and I truly I'm not
attacking you personally Wilmar and I
would enjoy and hope that we will have a
conversation one day I really do
but what is it that you really mean I'm
not moving there somehow I'm better I'm
still a good California liberal even
though we've got the Andromeda Strain
here and everyone's got their heads
wrapped in plastic bags and no one goes
out and it's depressing and there's
crack needles or whatever you do with
crack they don't do pipes they're pipes
I guess
so what are you people actually saying
and then Barry's like oh yeah yeah yeah
and then all the New York people they've
moved down to Florida too so what is it
that you guys are saying so the so the
question if you want to get to the
question
the question run DeSantis do you support
him yes or no Barry Weiss
do you support him yes or no you know
it's right here you know it's wrong you
live in Los Angeles just like Bill Maher
you know how [ __ ] up that place is
sorry one more time that's it I will do
it again right you get it okay so would
you support Ron DeSantis how about how
about Glenn young can I mentioned this a
couple weeks ago so you guys you're the
good liberals right you're the good
liberals we're against wokism we don't
want critical race theory in schools we
don't want to teach neo-racism okay
great you talk about it all the time did
you publicly say whether you would have
supported Glenn young or not uh Bill
Maher did you say after the election
that that's really great that that
Republican won because otherwise another
Democrat was going to win and it was
going to get much worse for the kids in
school who were being taught that
they're racist and locked down and put
in masks and then to Barry's point
they're all going to be even more
depressed
I built a case here guys
I feel like I did I've been trying to
get this off my chest in the right way
for quite some time so I think for the
rest of us right so for you watching
this for any of us that have roughly got
stuff right that that we want these
people to get the right ideas right so
that's the takeaway here I want these
people to wake up but at some point if
you get everything wrong you tell people
to vote the wrong way and then two years
later
you just say the same [ __ ] that everyone
else has been saying and then all of us
we applaud you for it it's so great it's
a real problem it's a real problem so I
guess really the question then is what
makes these people liberals anymore
what makes them leftists anymore and
what makes them Democrats more than
anything else okay what really is it and
it always comes down to two things it
seems to me
it comes down to abortion they love
abortion lefties love abortion I don't
want to get into the whole abortion
thing at the moment okay they love
abortion that's a big one and then it's
the religion thing and for Bill Maher
who's been the you know I'm the biggest
atheist and religious people are all
morons and backwards and you know
praying to their Sky spaghetti God and
everything else he has I don't know how
he digs himself out of that hole right
like he's gone so deep on that to say oh
my God it turned out that the religious
people and the conservative people have
called racist and stupid all these years
like how do I actually kind of have that
Maya culpa and go oh maybe you guys kind
of did know something maybe there were
some time tested ideas that I should
have maybe paid a little more attention
to where there's a reason you're all not
bananas or you do see the truth before
we do or something like that I don't
know how he does that as for Barry as
far as I know she's a somewhat
conservative Jew so I suppose she's more
okay with the religious part of it but
it's religion and abortion because the
other stuff like like at this point do
you think big government programs are
good do you think affirmative action is
good do you think giving money to poor
people to keep them in Cycles or poverty
is good so I don't think they're stupid
I don't think Bill Maher or Barry or
these five remaining good Liberals are
stupid so it's like if you if you don't
think that stuff then it comes down to
abortion and religion and it's like get
there guys what can I do this is my
message to you guys and I I suppose this
should be the message for any of you
watching this to any of your
non-insane liberal friends if you get it
if you're getting it now if you're
getting how badly the Democrats on the
leftists destroyed so much of the
country and the cities and everything
else it does not mean you have to be a
republican but let's get you over there
let's get you over the hump otherwise
is this good or bad what Bill Maher and
Barry Weiss are doing if they get
everything right but then at the end
it's like okay maybe you shouldn't have
you know helped destroy Donald Trump
because things would be a lot better
right now obviously if Donald Trump was
President right or if Ron DeSantis
becomes president or any Republican
becomes president but so if at the end
you're always going to do the wrong
thing then is this net good or bad it's
like yeah it's nice that you're not
completely insane I guess that's what it
is it's like I should send them a mirror
and then also we could probably we can
have one custom-made I think you can get
those little trophies custom made and
it's like congrats you're not completely
bananas and you can put it on your
mantle like that would be that
whoo segment one everybody can I get a
ground of Applause here or something
yeah can I a little passion guys a
little cheering woo
what
would all right
let's continue and I'll talk more about
crazy Democrats and you tell me if this
guy secretary Department of Homeland
Security secretary Alejandro mayorcas
you tell me if this is the guy that
should be in charge of illegal
immigration or not we've got videotape
unlawful presence in the United States
will alone not be a basis for an
immigration enforcement action
can we play that again because he
couldn't have possibly I mean he's a
Democrat these are good people lawful
people people with good ideas he
couldn't have the guy in charge of
immigration couldn't have
unlawful presence in the United States
will alone not be a basis for an
immigration enforcement action wait
sorry maybe my ear thing is not right
today let me get this in it that can't
be I couldn't maybe I didn't hear one
more time unlawful presence in the
United States will alone not be a basis
for an immigration enforcement action
did you get that did you get that this
is the guy in charge of the border and
he is basically saying if you can figure
out a way to get in we ain't gonna boot
you possibly not do anything and maybe
we'll even give you some money uh if you
figure out a way to get in we're not
going to put you how insane is that let
me read the quote one more time unlawful
presence in the United States will alone
not be a basis for immigration
enforcement action
so to link this to the previous segment
for just one second Bill Maher Barry
Weiss you want to prove me wrong you
want to show me you're getting to the
end of the road tweet about this today I
dare you I'll retweet you tweet about
this today that this ridiculous buffoon
in the Oval Office appointed this guy
mayorkus to be in charge of our borders
and now we are literally saying if you
are here illegally but you don't do
anything bad we just ain't gonna do
anything about it that's not how a
country is run dare I quote that orange
guy who said Without Borders you don't
have a country well that's pretty much
where we're at at this point so again
what is it that Democrats are doing that
is good what is it that these Liberals
are doing they don't believe that if you
are here illegally that is you're
breaking the law right right then and
there and by the way there's nothing
anti-immigrant about this and there is
nothing racist about this or anything
else Nations have orders that's how it
works every nation on Earth has borders
what they do in those borders is up to
them I personally
would prefer not to live in a country
where the people in charge said oh if
you can just come here you can have all
of our stuff and all of the benefits and
by the way we'll let you vote right
these idiots in New York City they're
letting illegal immigrants vote you
think they might vote for more
government programs for them which will
take more from the legally tax paying
citizens I mean do you see how the whole
game works man
these people are insane so
what do we do what do we do well why why
would it be that people would be insane
right like why would it so what what's
going on in their mind give the devil is
due so when when mayorcus says this in
his mind he's saying well we want to be
somewhat nice to these people right like
some people got here one way or another
and maybe they had kids here and by the
way there are plenty of people who got
here illegally who end up being really
good citizens and get educations and
start businesses and work real hard and
all of those things so I'm not even
against any of those people as
individual human beings it's just simply
does a system work or not do police
actually do policing do border agents
actually guard the Border just like
anything else right like do you just let
anyone walk into your house and if you
happen to walk outside to pick up the
newspaper and the door is open so
someone walks in and creates a camp in
your living room do you just let them
stay but for some reason we do this odd
thing with our country so we really need
to think seriously about getting rid of
the demo cracked I'm sorry that's what
it all comes down to at this point and
it ain't because the Republicans are so
great but they're not batshit loony
speaking of batshit Looney great segue
Dave uh CNN have you seen this channel
they've got this stelter guy The Potato
Man and he's got now his sidekick Oliver
Darcy who I think sort of used to be a
conservative and then he went the other
way which these people like what's the
deal what's the deal with that uh well
they had a guest on who just made even
less sense than what you'd usually find
on CNN but that's that's the goal right
the goal of this kind of coverage is to
freak people out to cause them to live
in fear ironically a lot of the
fear-mongering is about the things that
are not actually mortal threats and then
there's ignoring the things that are
mortal threats you know covet isn't real
and climate change isn't real I would
argue that to me anyway those things are
a little bit scarier or have been
scarier at various points in the past
couple of years and instead it's about
the Immigrant hordes and the senile
president and critical race Theory
brainwashing your kids and and things
that are you know if if not just
exaggerated invented out of whole cloth
oh right that's right critical race
Theory being taught in school you all
know this is happening all over the
place it's exactly why Glenn young can
won in Virginia yes they try to get you
on some definition of critical race
theory that it's not exactly what's
taught but we are we know they're
dividing classes by race they're making
it easier for certain students based on
skin color gender or whatever to get
into certain clubs or to play different
sports well you know all of this stuff
so she's saying okay it's just invented
out of whole cloth it's either
exaggerated or invented out of Holocaust
also Biden's cognitive decline it's like
uh that is a problem that is a problem
you know there's this Putin guy and he's
not this really great guy you may want
to do some bad stuff in the world and
Putin you may want to invade Ukraine it
seems like it's going to happen now I
don't know what we're supposed to do I
don't I personally I don't think we
should do anything probably like it just
kind of sucks but I don't think we have
the wherewithal as a country to really
do anything at the moment but do you
think that Putin is afraid of Joe Biden
who obvi obviously has severe cognitive
decline and to link this to our previous
story as well it's like that's one of
the things we don't talk about but
suddenly when one of the good liberals
either Jon Stewart or Bill Maher or
somebody will talk about Biden's
cognitive decline publicly well then
suddenly everyone will be talking about
it and all of us crazy right-wing
conservatives they'll go oh well you
guys were still racists and conspiracy
theorists and everything else but you
know now we're going to just say the
thing that you've been saying for uh two
years so what's interesting about this
is it shows it it's just one of those
things where
it shows you the layer being peeled off
these people they lie about all of these
things right they lie about critical
race theory in school they lie about
Biden's cognitive decline you know all
the stuff about you know Brett Kavanaugh
is a serial rapist the Covington kids
are all racist Donald Trump very fine
people like you know all they lie about
absolutely everything but
when something pops up
that is somewhat true like critical race
theory in schools and some of this other
stuff wokism all of the nonsense that's
exaggerated or invented out a whole
clock like you see the difference there
when we lie it's we're lying for the
greater good or something like that and
that's a little bit different but this
brings us into the fourth story uh which
is all about that Joe Biden there were
some really interesting uh video from
Biden's press conference a couple days
ago I think it was on Thursday or Friday
if I'm not mistaken been very busy over
here uh where a news max reporter I
think it's James Rosen uh I believe it
was James Rosen yeah we'll see in just a
sec uh he actually commented on Biden's
cognitive of the crime yes
thank you very much for this honor James
Rosen with Newsmax I'd like to um I'd
like to raise a delicate subject but
with utmost respect for your life
accomplishments and the high office you
hold
a poll released this morning by
political morning consult
found
49 of registered voters
disagreeing with the statement Joe Biden
is mentally fit
not even a majority of Democrats who
responded
uh strongly affirmed that statement
well I'll let you all make the Judgment
whether they're correct well so the
question I have for you sir if you'd let
me finish is why do you suppose such
large segments of the American
electorate have come to Harbor such
profound concerns
about your cognitive Fitness thank you
I have no idea
that was it I have no idea and then he
mumbled something a little bit earlier
before that now look I don't want to
make light of cognitive decline I don't
want to make light of Dementia or
Alzheimer's or any of that stuff I've
told you guys many times I spent a lot
of time with my Grandma Elaine who I
absolutely adored and loved and laughed
with more than anyone else on this Earth
uh when she developed dementia in her
last couple years and a lot of
repetition and frustration and then some
good times happen too because you you
forget some some of the pain in life and
she sort of became who she was supposed
to be at the end but I'm not diminishing
any of the horror related to any of that
because it will affect everyone one way
or another well whether it affects you
personally or someone in your family or
friends or anything that being said Joe
Biden is purportedly the president of
the United States he's supposed to be in
charge uh he's supposed to be the guy
with the finger on the Button he's
supposed to be the guy that is the pilot
of the plane the captain of the ship 50
percent basically half of the people in
the country do not believe he's right so
whether he has dementia or just old
person syndrome or something else or
it's just that he's old and there's a
lot of freaking pressure on him and
suddenly his stutter is coming back
that's what they're sort of telling us
like whatever it is if half the people
think that there is something truly
wrong with you and we all know about the
mumbling the confusion and forgetting
people's names and everything else it's
like whatever the truth is whatever
specifically the truth is related to a
diagnosis or whatever it's like that's
actually secondary too there's a
legitimacy problem even with Democrat
but note that was a Newsmax reporter
it's not talked about on NBC it's not
talked about
on you know CNN or read about in The New
York Times Washington Post or anything
but it will be right and when it will be
then they'll all go oh we all knew we
all knew and then you're going to watch
people in the administration and they're
going to go well I wanted to tell
everybody I was the guy going
something's not right here and it seems
odd to me that they have to drug him
before he goes on stage or whatever it
is that they do to him or that he had to
keep going to bed at 2 p.m and we put a
lid on everything at 3 P.M and blah blah
blah blah blah so they the rats on the
ship they're gonna bolt when they
realize that the ship is sinking right
they're going to get on the life rafts
um but this is a problem this is a
problem that we just don't do these
things honestly in real time no pun
intended related to the Mars segment
before it's like we can all see things
but the airlock on the system doesn't
let us all talk about it at the same
time and maybe that was all okay for
many many years but in the time of the
internet and social media it doesn't
kind of work too many of us are
realizing the truth and and what do you
do with all that to that point on NBC's
Meet the Press which is basically a
Democrat program Chuck Todd is obviously
a Democrat okay obviously even on NBC
even Chuck Todd is having to slightly
address some of this stuff that's how
bad it's gotten that's how how much
bludgeoning there is in this situation
take a look new NBC News polls suggests
Mr Biden does need a reset because he's
lost his identity a bit he's no longer
seen as competent and effective he's no
longer seen as a good commander-in-chief
or perhaps most damaging as easy going
and likable in fact just five percent of
adults say Mr Biden has performed better
than expected as president one of the
many lowest firsts and fewests in our
poll and as we kick off our meet the
midterms coverage heading into November
the NBC News political unit developed
what we're calling a midterm meter it's
based on previous election Cycles it's
basically three poll numbers you need to
know best I'm going to start with the
prep the most important number to
understand uh the direction of the
midterms it's job approval here the
president's job approval rating sitting
at 43 percent if you look at history
history shows that kind of presidential
approval rating leads to a shellacking
for the party in power how about the
mood of the nation well let me show you
this right now our wrong track Nation's
on the wrong track number sitting at 72
percent second poll in a row where we've
been over 70 percent it's only the third
time in our polls history over 30 years
we've had two tracks that uh were that
off that again would put you in
shellacking territory for the party in
power
okay so when Chuck Todd at msnb or NBC
it's all the same [ __ ] but at NBC is
ringing the alarm right when he's
sounding the Bell when he's screaming
about all this stuff now look we know
that in the midterm elections usually
the incumbent president's party gets
whacked right it's just what happens it
happened to Obama it happened to Clinton
before that it happened to Bush it
happened to Trump like the people are
just like oh this guy isn't so great or
not as great as we thought he was going
to be so like the other guys come in and
it's always easier to be more robust in
your attacks and everything else when
you're not the party that's in charge in
essence so things are obviously tracking
really well for the Republicans and in
this case it's not just because Biden's
a disaster it's because Republican
states are being run better at the
moment there's something called policing
you know there's something called
election Integrity there's something
called you know allowing people to go to
work and not locking everybody down and
not forcing them to be injected like
there's a lot of stuff happening right
now but what Chuck Todd is doing there
is he's warning Biden basically because
he realizes how bad it is so that that's
good now again Chuck is he's a Democrat
obviously he's pretending right he's
pretending to be this impartial thing
but what he really wants to happen which
is why he's doing the segment is Biden
to fix this thing not because he's he's
just an American who would want things
to be better but he doesn't want his
guys to lose power but I don't even want
to make this about Chuck Todd's too
specifically the point is that to link
this entire show together if I had a
thread through this entire show
we all see something ain't right we all
see something right sometimes we don't
all see it at the exact same time
but now I think it's our job
to help the people who aren't seeing it
as clearly as us get to that conclusion
and that is not to say you got to run
around with a republican pin of an
elephant on your lapel I do not consider
myself a republican believing in a set
of ideas is separate them being part of
a political party I have differences of
opinion
with mainstream Republicans I consider
myself begrudgingly pro-choice you you
guys know all this stuff there are some
in the conservative movement who are not
happy about my marriage I accept all of
these things I have found these people
to be open to debate and care about
ideas and know why they believe what
they believe and there's nothing left on
the other side so my message Barry Weiss
and Bill Maher if you're watching this
is let's talk about it let's talk about
it as a matter of fact I won't put ads
on the show or I'll donate whatever we
make to any charity of your choice but
otherwise otherwise I gotta keep going
after you right like I gotta not going
after you because I think you're bad
people
but at some point
it's a problem it's a problem if you're
stopping a whole slew potentially
millions and millions of other people
from making the right choice if you know
what is real and what is true and you
just won't do something because you
don't you still want to be invited to
nice parties or Bill Maher I don't want
to live in Florida and you still want to
live in Beverly Hills and do all that
well then it's a
problem
so a couple comments from the locals
community and then uh I think I'm gonna
feel like I need to like shower or
something after this one coach Rob says
Jesus Dave Rubin it's Monday morning you
got me all wound up please end with
Clyde and what a great thing David Janet
made for dinner last night well we don't
have any of our stuff so we're literally
working off one frying pan and one pot
so it's been a lot of pasta uh last
night we had friends over and we just we
ordered in some pizza But Clyde is doing
great Michael Frankie by the way bought
him a alligator today so Clyde's been
chewing on an alligator I just posted a
picture over there on the Twitter uh
hope says uh way to use the F-bomb
perfecto
sometimes it just it's in you you know
what I mean it's sitting in you and you
don't want to say it because you don't
want them to hurt you in the algorithm
but you must say it because otherwise
you'll just explode and that's what
happened there NT says Biden's poll
numbers will only continue to continue
to go down this is the most inept
corrupt incompetent Administration we've
ever seen ever
yes you are correct uh guys part one of
my interview with Marco Rubio it's up
right now on the uh the YouTuber is
coming out later today it'll be out
later today soon part one of my
interview with Marco Rubio uh I believe
it's up on vocals already the full
interview yes it is up on local 30 full
interview we did about an hour he is my
senator from the great and Free State of
Florida we figured it would be
appropriate that my first interview here
in Florida should be with either Rubio
or DeSantis we're working on the
DeSantis situation part one will be up
on YouTube shortly the full episode is
already up ad free over at
reubenreport.locals.com and I will be on
Charlie Kirk's show uh later today and
Lara Trump's show The Right View later
today I had a busy day and I got to get
back to Ikea all right I hope you enjoy
the show everybody do me a favor again
make sure you're subscribed and all of
that stuff and uh and I suppose think
about what I said and do you agree do
you disagree and what are you going to
do about it let me know